welcome to this video a stigmatised is
the opponent but he stopped playing
which is yeah okay it's just not good as
what i wanted to say some moves are good
to get a game going so let's see um pick
up the room yeah I have to confess you
still have not looked at something what
am I going to play a case getting for
the delayed exchange variation anyway
not the absolute main line with them
rookie one so I get this this opening
here yeah they normally play F 6 mm
correctly Bishop f6 a system of an idea
let's just try that don't really see it
the moment white is wrong okay there's
some pressure on this porn I understand
hmm yeah okay address that is so really
true yeah what black wants to do here
black has one issue this night here on
descent is not well placed I'd like to
reroute it to e6 g6 or c5 night be 86 in
this kind of business and with the
bishop Iran f6 and he's now got all
pieces on that porn it's somewhat tricky
empty move the night but ok or not not
really varied that much oh you removed
this night yeah what does he going for
she going for f4 in this position
not God really I don't really fear that
that's what I'm trying to say but
feeling you can also play Bishop g5 in
this position maybe why not activate
this a little bit it's not so clear what
it is doing i have to admit bit okay now
i could actually play f6 and then 98
it's kind of weird putting it on g5 this
position is rather slowish why nots
Bishop can go to h6 and they have night
f-86 in the in the works I am if it
seems that really wants to go F for
badly yeah okay can play that not sure
it's tushar play if he goes f4 now takes
takes bishop age 6 met some complicated
stuff but i should have some kind of
counter play okay here what do I do here
I can retreat should I retreat or should
I take if I take no F takes is far less
of a problem because of age for having
weakened the Kings side so I don't want
to take that much the bishop I mean
after everything on dark squares the
bishop has all nice and good but hmm
it's not so clear what this dark squared
Bishop is doing and here i have an easy
plan putting the knight on d4 which is
really one of my favorite devices and
chess putting the night in the middle
and ask him okay do you tolerate this
piece or not and if he's not tolerating
it exactly he has to play this damn ugly
move it is very ugly c3 he essentially
has to push c4 I mean otherwise he's
going to get in trouble with them with
the pawns I mean probably you will get
in trouble there anyway
in fact here the doubled porn is
something advantageous for black I have
to have open default and can put some
pressure on those I mean okay it's not
like he's losing or so but it looks kind
of nice maybe you can go age 66 f form
but while the bishop is blunted now on
be too so I don't know what is my plan
actually I could go Queen f7 queen s or
between d7 f7 okay supporting here I
wonder I shall play age six or not but I
think I can start to double controlling
f5 g-form can be I can only be useful
for me I think no thread in our rookie
age is his has to play some ugly moves
now maybe maybe can play C for 495 I
can't remove the night and play c6 this
is a difference knight on d5 can always
be kicked out pretty pretty easily yeah
he's doing he's doing that however it
would put pressure on f6 hmm it's not
look that great how do I get how do I
get seasick sin quickly
I have to also control v6 that is a
quite important
and f4 might come quindi aid is very
slow but ok he's not really threatening
that much to take b6 ok I just come to
this 95 rope f88 and if i get if i move
the night now and place his six he can
never take b6 because this night is
going to get trapped yes that that is
the move that makes things murky really
is but completely unsure i want to make
our make of it i wonder if i should i
come on let's do that and 94 undecided
yeah if I would like to allow him to
take stinks yeah but this is also
threatening something if it takes it and
I take with the pawn the night has no
retreat squares absolutely no no one
which also flies a little bit for my
bishop i have to admit here then what f5
if i go g5 what a strange position
cannot get at my my bishop ok very
difficult stuff f5 know is the critical
after see takes
si si 696 okay
hmm yeah I wonder in g five time whining
come on let's do that difficult takes
takes an IDF 6i have Roo k f6 I think he
can make a draw which is not so great
but this time warning signal that kind
of told me to make a move he can take
take Knight f6 I mean take on I cannot
actually hmm yeah and it's probably
better even pigs takes its a double
attack but you can still probably do
that okay now i have to take cares no no
big thought process necessary if he
takes g5 now i can take with the Queen
actually oh that's an interesting way to
play I still don't see where the night
is going C 6 9 p-6 would be 897 group
III it looks deadly come on let's do
that o night c7 I overlooked nuts is
certain entirely oh wow okay
I totally overlooked that he can go to
c7 ok I cannot tolerate the night anyway
so rather let him take it and see what
to do now I have to tread queens now and
check ok well this will be difficult
difficult to do anything it's completely
blocked the only idea that i have is
king up to e5 and no no no I still have
one idea this is good i'm going to try
playing on time trying for b5 I can do
that maybe can I know it is also a bit
risky my king is kind of quite resigned
ya mean it's no reason to take a draw I
have selected b5 idea yeah that was very
very difficult around here I think I
mean I'm in pretty pretty good shape
really but it wasn't easy to do maybe I
made some mistakes in this this and yeah
i wasn't sure i think in retrospect with
hindsight let's say i should have played
h6 which is kind of wasn't clear wasn't
clear to me by should play that or not
but it is better it is really better him
I allowed him to play this this and this
really made f6 vulnerable yeah I I
wasn't sure if I should play a sticker
or not but I should have done that it
really makes his counter play ideas and
more difficult the problem is my plan is
very simple Queen d7 rook the eighth
Queen f7 and then b3 is some just
terribly weak and yes to I mean he's
suffering from d3 and p3 weaknesses
Queen on f7 also looks at this point
it's actually very good you know that's
what I should have done
I mean here it's still not not bad for
black but it is far less how less
convincing therefore I know the comp
gives night before intending to take on
d5 with the bishop with a big advantage
quite surprisingly I did not expect that
yeah probably that the point is that
whenever why it takes here that this
counter idea is is so dangerous that it
is getting getting bad for black / white
minus 1 point 3 hmm yeah maybe I can
just take that know that that's our game
yeah that's better I'll night before is
better I did not really appreciate that
that seems to keep an edge as well but
it's less convincing I guess take stakes
yeah and now my idea was to trap this
night actually it has no squares after
see 696 Quincy 78 is strapped so white
has to do something drastic which is
this Oh f5 and now hey I should have
gone back to e6 they are kg5 and here
I'm actually losing ok interesting how
exactly am I losing not do that that's
pretty clear thing but this is actually
losing I was thinking I can take ruchi
form why I still haven't figured out why
I'm losing of course I'd f6 simply oh
how sick is that I was I was thinking
that here I can take but check have a
look at this this is this year's
devastating totally devastating Wow hey
ok
yeah I have no moves that simply have no
move yeah like between I don't know
where I mean after a move roop g7 Knight
f6 sa1 here Rock have six yeah this is a
very nice example of excellent
coordination of pieces like a complete
toast I was I was always thinking that
that he would go here let's say and then
Here I am yes I'm sorry this is this is
a golf course yeah you can can check me
again give this perpetual but may I did
not see that you can give up the Queen
yeah and this is not not really working
mmm yeah I'd see success a song as so 97
too late actually I was just seeing this
idea which is completely winning I
believe like here here it isn't winning
hook be one is saving the day yeah okay
this this is winning chat with this
check is that one and saves okay because
i don't have rupee aid mmm yeah it's
there are some somewhat inconvenient new
details here yeah let's say i mean i
want it i would like to play rook f7 but
Queen evaders checkmating me so hmm if I
have tried to winch SI usted and I'm
trying to win moving the rook somewhere
like here then I'm going to can't get
killed him check checkmate so funny way
yeah so if it could have taken on b6 ok
197 does make some sense yeah I returned
the exchange which is not yeah i can
actually i ah now I see the computers is
what it wants to do it differently i was
simply
I just wanted to get rid of this and I
it's simply so unnerving to have this
piece like around your king but okay his
queen is not active the compass is
suggesting this which is this is
stronger yeah like it's kind of cutting
off all the squares and intends to play
this and this and then I'm actually
staying with a pawn up that this prom or
some more precise and this way can't
this is a drawn I mean but I still
declined because i saw i still have this
b5 idea yeah first of all blocking
everything and then i can go for be five
but it is very risky i'm not even sure
that it is any good be five because well
my king is like rookie six is made yeah
so if he invades it's it's it's not
clear um yeah the comp in fact says abcb
rook a 2x takes and here we see the
problems that sometimes are connected
with the King position now that's kind
of ugly I have to after I'm sorry after
abcb look at you I have to be have to
play better not not quite sure what I
should do maybe this this and rook takes
this might be okay pigs check this this
kind of thing might be a draw yeah beef
be hi this is risky but okay I wanted to
do something and it actually paid off
aunty he basically lost some time he
reside because he cannot make the term
control on time control is wrong and
cannot finish the game in time with them
this deficit here off of 18 seconds
17 seconds but ok by now it is very good
yeah he cannot defend those pawns ok
well thanks for watching